on va donc parler d'écologie de
l'information si nous sommes ici tous ce
soir si on est ensemble c'est parce
qu'on partage un intérêt pour la
connaissance voire une passion pour la
connaissance
ça fait du bien d'apprendre ça nous
grandit ça nous libère
ça nous fait nous remettre en question
mais imaginez imaginer que toutes les
sources d'information que vous regardez
soit pollué qu'en fait leurs objectifs
ne soient pas de vous informer mais soin
de vous diminués de vous limiter de vous
rapetisser de vous renfermez sur vous
même c'est assez cauchemardesque non
c'est vraiment un cauchemar
et c'est pour ça que je suis là ce soir
parce que je pense que c'est vraiment
vers ça qu'on va notre système notre
écosystème informationnel est attaqué de
toutes parts et il est en danger il est
attaqué par exemple par les fakes news
bien évidemment cette pollution massive
ordonné voulu industrialiser qui n'a
pour seul objectif que de nous tous que
de changer la façon dont nous pensons
dont nous voulons agir bref qui nous
enlève notre libre arbitre et on a vu
les conséquences sur des élections très
récemment
cet écosystème est aussi attaqué dans sa
diversité
je n'ai même pas besoin de vous demander
qui parmi vous à regarder google twitter
ou facebook aujourd'hui et qui a acheté
un journal je sais très bien quelle est
la proportion l'information à laquelle
nous accédons aujourd'hui passe par
quelques portes très limité et tous les
médias
toutes les sources d'information doivent
passer par ses portes pour pouvoir nous
atteindre
quelle est la conséquence logique
imparable vous prenez les médias et bien
énormément de médias peut être la
majorité demandent à leurs journalistes
d'écrire pour google d'écrire pour
l'algorithme de google d'employer les
termes qui vont faire que les articles
vont ressortir d'employer les titres qui
vont faire que nous allons cliquer
dessus
ça n'a plus rien à voir avec du
journalisme c'est même le contraire du
journalisme des journalistes qui
écrivent pour des algorithmes au lieu
d'écrire pour des hommes et des femmes
une autre attaque se fait sur la
circulation de l'information
les algorithmes facebook nous limite
nous renferme dans des bulles en
fonction de ce que l'algorithme
l'algorithme pense être qui nous sommes
du coup on voit des choses qui nous
renforce lorsque nous pensons nous
limite est en fait nous empêche de nous
enrichir nous empêche d'apprendre et
tout ça ça a des conséquences
dramatiques sur la façon dont nous
évoluons sur notre progrès humain sur
les démocraties entre autres et quand on
remonte à un facebook que nous répond
mark zuckerberg mais c'est une techno
facebook c'est une techno on met à
disposition la techno pour que les gens
puissent communiquer entre eux ce que
les gens échangent entre eux c'est pas
notre responsabilité
quelle blague vous avez le pouvoir
d'influencé deux milliards de personnes
et vous n'êtes pas responsables cette
absurde
évidemment que facebook est responsable
évidemment que mark zuckerberg est
responsable et cette responsabilité
évidemment un niveau moindre je la
partage
je suis moi même entrepreneur j'ai créé
une entreprise avec mon associé qui
s'appelle si l'abs et qui a développé un
algorithme un moteur de rédaction
qui permet de produire automatiquement
des contenus des textes des articles ses
articles ou les vendons à nos clients
qui peuvent être des médias le monde
france tv radio france nous utilisent
qui peuvent être des sites web
e-commerce tourisme peu importe
et nous diffusons comme cela de
l'information avec ses articles ont
produit des centaines de milliers des
millions d'articles par an est-ce que je
peux me permettre de dire ah mais c'est
une techno je suis pas responsable
évidemment je suis responsable
évidemment que à partir du moment où les
articles que la technologie de mon
entreprise produits sont lus qu'ils
peuvent influencer des gens évidemment
que je porte une responsabilité est donc
évidemment je dois contrôler ce qui sort
ce que nous produisons et essayer de le
faire de manière équilibrée saine
éthiques
il ya des cas où c'est simple quand on
nous demande on l'a fait à maintes
reprise quand on nous demande de
produire de faux avis cet hôtel il est
génial je suis là il est complètement
pourri
évidemment qu'on peut pas faire ça
pourtant on nous l'a demandé à de
nombreuses reprises
c'est simple on dit non quand on nous
demande de participer à la propagande
d'un état qui se trouvent très à l'ouest
on a été contacté par très à l'est par
dont on a été contacté par un média et
j'étais très content mais quand j'ai
compris qu'en fait l'objectif c'était de
faire la propagande d'un état qui
évidemment n'a pas mes idéaux
démocratiques
simple non mais il ya d'autres questions
il ya d'autres questions sur lesquelles
on ne sait pas quelle est la réponse on
ne sait pas par exemple est-ce qu'on
doit forcer nos clients a indiqué sur
nos articles qu'ils ont été écrits par
une machine
ça se discute est-ce qu'on peut accepter
pour un média normale avec une
orientation politique tout à fait
légitime d'orienter nos articles pour
suivre cette orientation politique
je ne sais pas
et donc comme je ne suis pas sûr comme
je ne veux pas décider
nous avons décidé de monter un comité
d'éthique composé de chercheurs
sociologues journalistes pour nous aider
à répondre à ces questions et je suis
persuadé que tous les tous les
producteurs d'information les
technologies de l'information devrait
avoir un tel comité d'éthique mais il
faut même aller plus loin
ces décisions là nous concerne tous nous
devrions donc avoir la possibilité de
nous exprimer de pouvoir dire oui ok les
experts ont dit quelque chose mais les
experts y vivent pas ma vie moi aussi
j'ai besoin d'exprimer mon opinion et on
devrait donc ouvrir cette discussion à
tout le monde c'est à dire avoir un site
web dans lequel nous posons des
questions et tout le monde peut y
répondre et tout le monde peut nous
interpeller vous pouvez nous interpeller
en nous posant des questions parce que
vous vous demandez si ce qu'on fait est
éthique ou pas et c'est normal et ça
devrait être fait par tous parce qu'en
fait nous sommes tous responsables
cet écosystème informationnel
c'est notre avenir c'est la façon dont
nous pensons c'est ce qui va définir nos
enfants nous avons un devoir une
responsabilité pour le protéger pour le
faire évoluer dans le bon sens
nous avons une responsabilité en tant
que consommateur on regarde les articles
on lit les articles et puis quand
l'article dit la même chose que ce qu'on
pense c'est cool on est content ça nous
renforce
lorsqu'on pense ça nous fait penser
qu'on est intelligent en fait puisque
ses écrits le problème c'est que c'est
pas parce que ça dit la même chose que
ce qu'on pense que c'est vrai
et donc en fait au lieu de nous rendre
intelligent ça nous rend bête il est
indispensable de réfléchir à
l'information qu'on est en train de lire
est-ce que ça a été écrit pour nous
informer ou est-ce que ça a été écrit
pour nous conditionner quelle est la
source qui a écrit avec quel objectif il
est nécessaire de se poser ces
questions-là
il est nécessaire également de
diversifier ses sources d'information je
consomme beaucoup de médias je suis
abonné à six médias parmi lesquels il y
à mediapart le figaro on peut
difficilement faire plus éloignées je
suis pas toujours d'accord avec
mediapart je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec le figaro mais le fait d'avoir ces
deux points de vue parfois très opposés
sur un même événement je pense que sam
enrichi je pense que ça me permet
d'avoir une meilleure vision de ce qui
se passe on a aussi une responsabilité
en tant que producteur quand vous faites
un like quand vous partagez un article
c'est pas anodin c'est un acte social
c'est un acte politique
vous êtes responsable nous sommes
responsables des articles que nous
partageons parce que ces articles
peuvent influencer les gens qui nous
suivent
et donc nous sommes responsables de
cette influence nous devons réfléchir à
ce qui est fait quand on partage quelque
chose est ce que la source est fiable et
est-ce que c'est pas simplement que
c'est cool de partager quelque chose qui
dit comme je pense et enfants nous
sommes responsables en tant que citoyen
ne pensez pas qu'on n'a pas le pouvoir
la possibilité de faire changer les
choses nous pouvons faire changer les
choses
je dirais même que nous devons faire
changer les choses
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec
facebook le pew research center a fait
un sondage
quelques mois après la révélation du
scandale facebook
quand on a révélé que facebook avait été
utilisé enfin que les données facebook
nos données avaient été utilisés
pour influencer de manière massive les
élections américaines qu'a révélé deux
sondages 26%
les américains qui avaient un compte
facebook
ce sont des abonnés 26%
parmi eux 44 % de jeunes ce sont des
abonnés de facebook
la bravo c'est un vrai acte citoyen
facebook nous a trahis facebook a donné
les moyens de truquer nos élections on
s'en va et puis en fait on a les moyens
d'agir rappelez vous on parle
d'écosystèmes écosystème de
l'information mais parlons d'un autre
écosystème l'écologie l'écologie avant
c'était un truc de quelques hurluberlus
qui criait au loup dans le désert tout
seul mais petit à petit ça a pris ti
tapis de plus en plus de personnes se
sont rendus compte qu'il y avait un vrai
enjeu qu'il y avait une catastrophe qui
se prépare et petit à petit les choses
ont bougé
une très grande partie de la population
mondiale a conscience que nous pouvons
détruire notre environnement nous
pouvons détruire le climat et cette
conscience a fait bouger les politiques
a fait bouger les états évidemment tout
n'est pas parfait dans l'écologie on le
sait bien mais ça a bougé
on peut faire la même chose pour
l'information
on peut déjà agir sur nous comme je les
dis on peut en parler autour de nous je
suis là pour ça vous pouvez le faire
aussi on peut apprendre à nos enfants
comment traiter l'information qui leur
arrive
on peut inventer ensemble une écologie
de la formation et ça vaut le coup donc
il ya plus qu'à y aller merci bien
[Applaudissements]